Verwaiste Schwimmhallen, zerstörte Zimmer.
Die Skilifte sind schon seit Jahren außer
Betrieb.
Der Wintersportort Heul Ri war einst das Sankt Moritz von Südkorea.
Tausende Wintersportler kamen jedes Wochenende, Touristen drängten sich auf den Pisten.
Doch dann ging der Betreiber Pleite.
"Alles liegt komplett in Trümmern, jetzt, wo das Ski-Gebiet geschlossen ist.
Alle Geschäfte sind zu.
Gästehäuser und Pensionen verfallen.
Niemand wird mehr hier herkommen, weil ja alles geschlossen ist."
250 Einwohner hat Heul Ri noch.
Sie hoffen darauf, dass sich durch die Olympischen Winterspiele im nahegelegenen Pyeongchang
doch noch etwas ändert und die Touristen
zurückkehren.
"Ich habe die Skiausrüstung behalten, falls die Station doch noch wieder öffnet.
Schließlich habe ich so viel Geld investiert.
Ich sage mir immer: 'Vielleicht, eines Tages…'"
Doch die Aussichten sind schlecht.
Die Behörden haben ihr Geld für die Olympischen Winterspiele in neue,
moderne Wintersportanlagen investiert.
Heul Ri ging leer aus und wird wohl nie wieder aus seinem Dornröschenschlaf erwachen.
Und wie es mit den Austragungsorten nach Ende der Winterspiele weitergehen soll,
ist ebenso fraglich.